aber ich meine tiefer als ich kann man
eigentlich auch schon ich habe ganze gar
nicht mehr legen also deswegen verstehen
das wäre irgendwo selbst du dich
überhaupt mal ja ich aber du schämst
dich viel weniger als ich es gibt
interessante studien die sagen das haben
eigentlich ein tief in den ligen des
gefühls empfinden ist es gibt eine
sendung die heißt naked attraction leute
lernen sich kennen komplett nackt die
kandidaten stehen in sohren und der
sichtschutz wird immer weiter
hochgefahren von unten nach oben kraft
jetzt zehn sich die leute nicht mehr im
übertragenen sinne ausholen und physisch
das was wir vielleicht mit der würde und
vereinbar finden finden andere völlig
unproblematisch was sehr interessant das
ist bei die die rebound diesem
französischen soziologen die er zum
beispiel sagt ja dass er sich für seine
herkunft steht nämlich aus ganz
einfachen arbeiter verhältnissen kommend
und jetzt ist er einer der wichtigsten
soziologen frankreich ich finde dieses
buch in der tat hochgradig bedenklich
was an diesem buch kritikwürdig ist dass
er zum beispiel kritisiert dass in
diesen akademiker kreisen ein jargon
gesprochen wird der leute wie ihn
ausgeschlossen hat nutzt genau die
gleichen mechanismen von denen er
behauptet sie hätten sich früher gegen
ihn gerichtet und ich verstehe dass das
ich an scham die ich sehr gut nachdem
philipp hat ja ein anliegen ist zu
beschreiben wie schwer es für ihn war
sich frei zu schaufeln als arbeiter kind
und dann als homosexueller
dieses buch leistet keinen beitrag zur
emanzipation man kann auch sich weigern
sich beschämen zu lassen sich weigern
sich beschämen zu lassen muss man ja
lernen meine lieblingsgeschichte ist als
ich in berlin war und vorbei gegangen
bin an einem typen der arme kerl hatte
so einen becher in der hand und dann
habe ich geld aus dem portemonnaie
genommen und habe ihm das geld welche
kürzlich spritzte graf er saß da und hat
mich angeguckt wie mich irgendwie
behämmert wäre ich ja auch schade dass
ich nicht dabei war
stopp
[Musik]